one last bit of language for you before
we start looking at some operations okay
remember the most important thing in a
polynomial is the degree right so
therefore the turn with the degree kind
of matters and therefore the coefficient
of that turn also kind of matters right
now we're not leading coefficient when
it's equal to one we give the whole
polynomial and love are sort of mean
because it's a really it's a it's a case
again that comes up so frequently it's
worth giving it a name it's a name you
actually already learned from quadratics
in fact here's a quadratic
there's the degree this is the leading
term so what's the leading coefficient
for that one it's one right so we call
this starts with M it's a word that
means morning one we call it a monic
quadratic right but all of these
polynomials if they have our leading
coefficient of one we call the
polynomial money a monic polynomial
which you know it comes from like mono
from one or rail and so on okay um so
monic polynomials come up again and
again and again which is why when you
see something frequently you give it a
special name so now let's have a look at
this right down to a question too
because it's really where the UM the
business end starts to get happening and
the rest of its really not as
interesting okay so I wonder if you can
squiggly you can see what they're doing
is they're borrowing the function
notation that they've we've already
talked about okay
we usually called our functions f for
function these are all polynomials so
instead of F for function they will very
frequently use P for polynomial okay so
we've got a pair of polynomials please
buy them and then because um they want
to talk about how to pull a nose you
track together the next letter after P
is cube even though it doesn't say of a
polynomial okay
so you've got this polynomial and then
your second one which is
is just quickly before we do any
operations on them can we identify these
pieces over here talking about st. Q for
instance okay
what's the degree when you look at it
there you go it's just squared right so
it's - okay that makes this the leading
yeah sorts of leading coefficient it's
one and what's the constant term -
problem I'm not gonna use any of that
particularly for these set of questions
but you need to start to recognize I can
I can read those features on okay now
are we interested operations right so
we're going to be able to add these two
together we can manipulate them in a
variety of ways adding subtracting and
multiplying are really easy we'll get to
the next operation energy pressing we'll
get to that on Thursday it's
substantially harder but this is going
to form a building block so okay I'm
gonna read this as P of X P of X that's
my function like phrasing coming in P of
X plus Q of X and all I need to do is
add these two together that's all I'm
doing
okay now noticing that all these
families of polynomials can you see
they'll very frequently have x squared
terms in them and now very frequently
have X cubed terms in them so what am I
do is I just want to match up the right
terms I'm sort of collecting like terms
put on a bigger scale so when I look at
both of these together both of them
together
how many x squared terms are there in
the whole lot it's just the one there's
just that x squared there so I'm just
gonna write it down x squared okay how
many X terms are there there's two
there's one in the top blowing oh no you
don't there's one bottom one um I took
before about how useful colors are if
you have some extra colors I'll use them
because they will seriously save you you
know missing terms or matching off the
wrong ones if you don't have colors go
buy some okay because they're reusable
there's that next turn there and they're
in P and Q okay so I'm gonna match them
up and I say well I'm adding things
right so 4x plus 7x that's how many
units
and done and lastly I've got a constant
turn
I've got a constant time in each one
right again I'm going to pair up one two
when I add them what do I get one no
problems okay that's really easy and
when we do is subtraction
okay one of the great things because you
have if you're following along with me
because you have paired up all of these
things already with colors that makes
the next process even easier right
don't forget order matters when you
subtract so I've already got that's
that's all X term X square term hanging
out there okay but notice I'm doing PE
takeaway Q takeaway Q right so I have no
x squared terms here and I'm taking away
an x squared term from here right so I
write down minus x squared
do you see that you see why it's
negative it's kind of subtracting Q so Q
is this whole polynomial here right so
I'm going line one take away line 2 line
one take away line two
so in some ways there's a zero missing
there and in fact later on especially
when we look at those things listen
you'll find some people will write it
like this they'll say even though
there's no x squared term there they'll
put one there so that they don't forget
there's something there but there's just
none of it okay zero take away one
negative one so that's why I'm negative
x squared minus x squared for X to take
my 7x I'm gonna say it and lastly
negative three take away - that's not -
three - two it gets even more negative
right when you add to negative so yeah
it's -5 isn't it okay be careful now I'm
not gonna do C which is just in reverse
order that's Q take away P but suffice
to say you're going to get a different
answer aren't you right for starters
instead of zero take away x squared
you'll get x squared take away zero okay
actually you know what really quickly we
don't even need to do the work you
because do you agree then if I have a
pair of numbers like this
if I take her through you know what the
answer is but that's the same as doing
this isn't it by putting a minus sign
here changes the order like if you're
not convinced just let me I'll expand it
and that's five take away three happy
okay
so if I know what P take away Q is then
what will Q take away pain be equal to
in relation to this isn't it just this
with a minus sign slapped out the front
do you see that like that changes the
order so this is negative P take away Q
do you see that you see that these two
are equivalent in the same way that
these two are equivalent so I don't even
need to do this subtraction I've kind of
already done it here I just turn
everything around and I'm done okay do
you see how we're taking advantage of
what you know about algebra in this
newer kind of sphere